este miércoles en San José inicia una
audiencia clave en el debate sobre el
laborato en Centroamérica la Corte
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
analizará el caso Beatriz versus el
estado de El Salvador Beatriz es el
nombre con que se le conocía a una
salvadoreña que en 2013 a los 22 años
sufrió una embarazó de alto riesgo la
joven padecía de lupus una enfermedad
que afecta el sistema inmunológico
además se diagnosticó que el feto se
estaba desarrollando sin cráneo y sin
cerebro por lo que 15 médicos le
recomendaron abortar sin embargo por
tratarse de uno de los cinco países de
América Latina y del Caribe donde el
aborto está prohibido en todas las
circunstancias ningún médico se animó a
practicarle la interrupción de embarazo
hoy en día en El Salvador la legislación
sigue intacta es decir que las mujeres
que aborten de manera voluntaria o
involuntaria en consideradas asesinas y
por ellas Hay penas de cárcel de hasta
50 años esta semana este lunes la madre
y el hermano de Beatriz declararon
esperar que ninguna mujer deba enfrentar
una situación similar sin embargo en
2021 el presidente nayib bukele descartó
cualquier cambio a la ley que rige el
aborto en el país